ازمه ماليه طاحنه يتعرض لها مستشفى
57357 الخاص بعلاج سرطان الاطفال وتهدد
باغلاق ابوابها فبعد ان اغلق فرع طنطا من
هذه المستشفى بشكل كامل بسبب قله التبرعات
وحتى الدعم الماليه الازمه تنتقل الى فرع
المستشفى في القاهره والذي قد يتم اغلاقه
ايضا خلال الايام القليله القادمه فيما
ضجت مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي بالعديد من
الصراخات والمناشدات للمساعده في انقاذ
هذا المستشفى من الاغلاق في وجوه الاطفال
المرضون معك
يعني ازمه المستشفى تتصاعد ومحاولات
مستنيته لاستقطاب تبرعات اولا كيف بدات
الازمه ما الذي حصل تحديدا
عن المستشفى المستشفى بدات سنه 2007 في
استقبال المرضى بطاقه 180 سرير
والمستشفى من يوميها لحد النهارده وهي
بتتوسع وصلنا في 2020 لطاقه الشعبيه 380
سرير وبقيت اكبر مركز متخصص لعلاج اورام
الاطفال في العالم
المستشفى لما وصلت للعدد ده وصلت لهذا
الطاقه الاستعمال الكبيره همم بقى البردن
والحمل الاقتصادي على المستشفى كبيره
والمستشفى كمان مرت من بدايه من 2015/2016
ببعض التحديات الاقتصاديه اللي حطت
المستشفى في همم همم في محكم ان هي محتاجه
تاخذ بعض القرارات للاستمرار في تقديم
احسن خدمه طبيه بالمجان للاطفال فال 2016
وظروف الاقتصاديه اللي حصلت اا وبعدها
2018 وحصل همم شويه هجوم اعلامي على
المستشفى همم وبعد كده الوباء العالمي
الكورونا خلت المستشفى اا محتاجه تاخذ
شويه بيزنس ديجينس قويه للاستمرار في
الميشن بتاعتها بتقديم اعلى جوده للخدمه
الطبيه للاطفال مرضى السرطان والقرارات
البيزنس والبيزنس او القرارات اللي اتاخذت
همم كانت كلها
لتخفيض التكاليف بدون المساس بجوده الخدمه
الطبيه المقدمه للطفل
اسمر اي تواصل مع الحكومه تواصل مع
مسؤولين بخصوص هذا التحدي كما وصفته الذي
يعانيه المستشفى
المستشفى 57 هي تبع وزاره التضامن
الاجتماعي وتاخذ على الاشراف من وزاره
الصحه وكذا وكذا جهه ووزاره في البلد
واحنا طول الوقت من يوم ما فتحت المستشفى
لحد النهارده في دعم وتسهيلات من كل
الجهات الرسميه المستشفى قائمه على
التبرعات وهمم ما فيش اي حد في الشعب
المصري ما تبرعش همم فزي ما باقول
المستشفى همم تتلقى الدعم من كل الجهات
الرسميه همم وتسهيلات من كل الجهات
الرسميه اا وهي قائمه على التبرعات وكل
الشعب المصري بيعتبر عن المستشفى همم ومن
اول يوم الكلام ده طب ده من كل يتبرع
دكتور يعني لماذا طلبيات من الادويه
والمعدات الطبيه الضروريه لم تصل للمستشفى
بعد
هي دي مش حاجه الخاصه بالمستشفى بس يعني
المستشفى
كجزء من مش حتى في مصر بس العالم كله
دلوقتي من ساعه الكورونا خصوصا والمشاكل
التي تحصل في الاستيراد والتصدير في مشاكل
في الافيلا بليتي بتاعه الادويه في كل
المستشفيات العالم همم
مريض السرطان احتياجاته كبيره جدا من
الادويه احتجاجات كبيره جدا من المستلزمات
والتقنيات المتقدمه همم هي هو التحدي
الحقيقي في ان احنا محتاجين بالاعداد اللي
عندنا ان احنا نستمر في الحفاظ على نفس
المستوى جوده الخدمه المقدم ومع زياده
اعداد ومع تاثر
الحاله الاقتصاديه للعالم عموما والدوله
وللمستشفى بالتبعيه همم كل احتياج للتبرع
زاد فهو التبرعات موجوده التبرعات همم
كميات ما قلتش لكن همم احتياجنا انت
تبرعات اكثر في الفتره دي همم مطلوب علشان
القدره الشرعيه بتاعه المستشفى قلت عن قبل
كده
[موسيقى]